You're making your Broadway debut in Meteor Shower.
Yes.
Yeah, this is exciting.
(applause)
Written by a scrappy young comic making his way up,
named Steve Martin.
Big up-and-comer, Steve Martin.
Big up-and-comer, yeah.
Haven't seen a lot of his stuff, but he was very promising.
Very promising.
Yeah, it's been interesting, because in rehearsal,
while we're rehearsing the play,
they do tweaks every night, so like,
we change things during the rehearsal during the day,
so there are times when the director says,
"So make sure, don't do the, don't do that move.
"You're gonna do this move tonight."
And then sometimes you're checking your phone,
you're like, "No, got it, got it, got it."
And then cut to 8:30 at night, and it's just like, you know.
That's not...
(Conan laughing)
Forgot the, just forgot the moves.
Yeah, you gotta walk that back.
The lights come up, and you're like, "Oh!"
(laughter and applause)
Now, how do you handle, the thing that makes people crazy,
a lot of actors, Broadway actors, say they can't stand
when people were talking in the crowd.
Oh, gosh, yeah.
Have you experienced that?
We have experienced it.
I did a production of Hamlet at the Public Theater here
in New York, earlier this year.
(applause)
Serious play.
And I'm sitting on the steps,
like next to an an audience member, with Oscar Isaac,
and Oscar Isaac, who is playing Hamlet,
he sits down next to this woman.
And this sweet little old woman,
she's just looking at Oscar.
And she just, as loud as she possibly can,
she just goes, "Are they gonna carry you out?"
(audience laughing)
And he says, he goes, "I don't know.
"I don't know, but watch."
And this same old woman, this same old woman,
this poor lady, she was just havin' a day.
Yeah.
She was having a little bit of a time in the front row,
and she was trying to be polite,
so while a guy was doing a monologue, she was like,
"I have to go to the bathroom.
"I have to go to the bathroom."
"Ma'am, you can wait."
"I can't wait."
"You can wait."
And he stops speaking in the monologue so her,
to get her voice up, he goes,
"The time thus and has happened here."
"I have to go number two!"
(laughter and applause)
It was amazing.
But it's not, being an improv performer,
you're used to people talking to you and stuff like that.
It's like, even when you talk to them,
then don't give you the response that you're
always looking for.
We've had people that come and watch the tapings,
whether it was here in New York or in LA,
and they're so used to watching the show on television.
Yeah, yeah.
That they'll be sitting there, and I'll come out,
and they'll just go, very loudly,
"He's taller than I thought!"
(audience laughing)
I'm here!
Right, I'm right here.
And sometimes, I've gotten this, too.
"Is he black?
(laughter and applause)
"The voice isn't black, is he Polynesian, Hispanic?
"Where's he from?"
Well, dammit, that was my next question.
(applause)
To answer the question, I've been half black for 46 years,
and I'm all black when it's super convenient.
(Conan laughing)
Sometimes you have to be all black, sometimes.
I didn't realize you had that power, all right.
Yes, I have that power.